the idyllic islands of french polynesia  may seem like a relaxing paradise of  pristine reefs and clear waters  but take a dip below the surface  are you ready for a swim  bakarava is a rectangular shaped atoll  located in french polynesia in the south  pacific ocean  the southern pass of farkarava is known  as the grey shark wall due to having the  highest concentration of grey reef  sharks in the world  since 2006 the sharks have been  protected from fishing which is  attributed to their population increase  during the day the sharks are fairly  docile and conserve energy ready to hunt  their prey at night  although the exact number of sharks  found in vaquerava is uncertain with  only 650 human residents it's likely the  people are outnumbered  [Music]  you